Speaker 1: A new report from inside it failed.
Former President Donald Trump's inner circle
shows that Donald Trump is now furious with
Kanye West and is claiming that West tried
to f him.
This is going from crazy to even crazier and
it all relates to this white supremacist dinner
as it is now being called.
Think of that term now being part of the news
cycle for days.
Trump's white supremacist dinner now the subject
and triggering factor for his ire against
Kanye West, as well as Nick Fuentes and others.
Article from NBC News lays it out.
Quite interestingly, the article is called
The Inside Story of Trump's Explosive Dinner
with Jay and Nick Fuentes.
What was supposed to be a private dinner ended
up being a political nightmare.
Now I want to be clear and make sure people
know some of the things that are in this article,
which seems well-enough sourced, let's put
it that way, are being denied by Nick one
tests.
But I actually believe that that doesn't mean
that much because one test may not even be
privy to some of what is here.
The narrative is compelling.
I encourage you to read it and we're linking
to it.
It's by Marc Caputo and it says Just two days
before Thanksgiving, Trump was planning to
have a private, uneventful dinner with an
old friend, Jay, the rapper formerly known
as Kanye West.
They arranged to have dinner Tuesday night
at Mar a Lago after some phone conversations.
But Trump may have been walking into a trap.
Trump has said he didn't know when tests the
white nationalist and anti-Semite or is background
that West said, hey, he wants to come in and
have dinner with us as well.
There is a damage control campaign now being
put together that the NBC News article explains.
But the most interesting part of this comes
under this section.
The master got trolled.
The headline grabbing attention on his guests
and therefore the subsequent fallout were
all but ensured by Trump before the dinner
when he made a grand entrance at 8 p.m. on
November 22nd.
Understand that at Mar a Lago there's a table
reserved for Trump and his guests.
It's in full view of everybody.
So it can have all the pomp and circumstance
that a narcissist like Donald Trump would
want.
So there was no question that everybody was
going to see who was there, but it ended up
not being a happy photo op.
Yay.
Criticized Trump for not doing enough to help
the Trump rioters.
He told Trump he might run for president and
that Trump should be his running mate, which
infuriated Trump reportedly who then attacked
Kim Kardashian Ye's ex-wife.
Ja later put out a video saying Trump is really
impressed with Nick Fuentes when to says he
praised Trump as my hero and criticized the
Santas.
And then the adviser that spoke to NBC characterizes
the entire thing as the master troll got trolled
kania punked Trump and there is a section
about Milo Yiannopoulos who I believe may
have actually really been the orchestrator
of this entire thing and the most interesting
paragraph maybe of the article.
Trump fumed afterward that Yeh had betrayed
him by ambushing him.
Quote He tried to f me, he's crazy.
He can't beat me, Trump said, according to
one confidant who then relayed the conversation
to NBC News.
Trump was totally blindsided.
The source said it was a setup.
Supposedly, some in Trump's orbit warned him,
Don't have dinner with Kanye, who's already
under fire for anti-Semitism, the inclusion
of Juan tests making it all the more volatile.
So first of all, none of this is the picture
of stability.
Kanye's not stable.
Trump is certainly not stable.
Nobody involved in this thing is even remotely
stable.
Now, Nick Fuentes is denying that this was
overtly a setup.
But the truth is that Fuentes may have simply
been a pawn in the setup rather than a participant.
For all we know, this sort of thing has Milo
Yiannopoulos fingerprints all over it, quite
frankly.
And as you know, I've been in touch with Milo
over the years.
It's been years since he agreed to come on
the program multiple times.
I've invited Milo to come on.
He has rejected the offer.
He's welcome to come on any time.
And I would love to talk to him about this.
But there's a few different things that are
important to understand.
One, seemingly nothing is below the office
of the president at this point in time.
Okay, consider how much American politics
has changed.
In 2000, four Democratic primary candidate
for president, Howard Dean screamed about,
we're going to go to Iowa where, you know,
he made a noise.
He screamed.
It ended his campaign.
It seems so quaint at this point in time where
Trump is having Kanye West at dinner and he's
surprised that.
Kanye's even crazier.
And then Kanye has a white nationalist in
tow and Milo Yiannopoulos is involved.
And they're having this dinner really in a
public setting where everybody can see.
So politics has changed dramatically in the
United States, that's for sure.
And by the way, imagine being Trump and ending
up surprised that Kanye is even crazier than
you are.
Like, it's sort of like a race to the bottom
here that's going on.
So who set up whom?
It's not completely clear at this point in
time.
But what does seem very clear is that Trump
never had a great team around him.
His 2016 team wasn't a great team.
They did end up getting him elected when we
have to give them credit for that.
Trump's 2020 team was even worse.
They failed to get him elected.
I don't know who's around Trump at this point
in time for what is a very early start to
his 2024 campaign.
But either it's a disastrous team or Trump
simply doesn't listen to them, which would
be pretty on brand with what we've learned
about Donald Trump.
Wacky, wacky times.
And I don't think these types of stories are
going to go away.
And we have to devote just a couple of minutes
to the continued middle of the night rantings
from Donald Trump.
Let's talk about that momentarily.